pensemos en los diferentes casos de uso
para las permutas de incumplimiento
crediticio digamos que yo tengo una
compañía por aquí y se le dio una
calificación w y claro esta calificación
se la da una agencia de calificación
crediticia puede ser por ejemplo muy
entre varias entonces lo que hacen estas
agencias es ver a esta compañía ve en
este negocio ve en su hoja de balance y
dicen ah ok bueno esta compañía no es
tan segura pero tampoco es tanto riesgo
le vamos a dar una calificación w ahora
digamos que hay un inversionista por
aquí este inversionista quiere prestar
dinero a la compañía entonces les presta
dinero y en retorno obtiene intereses
pero a este inversionista no le gusta la
calificación de la compañía
él quiere asegurarse de que a él se le
entregue todo aunque esta compañía por
alguna razón motivo circunstancia llegar
a quebrar entonces él va con algún
vendedor de permuta de incumplimiento
crediticio el más famoso eso era a dije
él va con ellos y le va a decir hey dije
parece te voy a pagar un poco cada año
puedes ver esto como una prima de
seguros y en cambio tú me vas a asegurar
en caso de un incumplimiento de pago por
esta compañía entonces aquí pongo seguro
y como digo es un poco tramposo porque
la compañía aeg no fue regulada como
seguro ahige no tiene que guardar dinero
y el poder aquí que tiene ahí es que la
agencia de calificación le da una doble
a a dije es una muy alta calificación
entonces a pesar del hecho de seguir
teniendo todos estos cargos la agencia
de calificación crediticia le dice hey
ya dije te seguiremos dando una
calificación doble a y asia dije
aprovecha su calificación doble a para
seguir firmando contratos para seguir
firmando seguros sin tener que guardar
dinero lo puedes ver cómo obtener dinero
gratis y bueno ese es un caso otro caso
podría ser quizás un banco de
inversiones crea algún tipo de entidad
con un propósito especial o un lugar de
obligación de deudas garantizadas y
tienen sus diferentes tramos aquí está
por ejemplo el tramo prioritario
sólo puede venderles fondo de pensiones
que sólo puedan comprar deudas
calificadas doble a fondo de pensiones
el banco de inversiones va a hija y dice
hey hey
puede esta entidad aquí comprar permutas
de incumplimiento crediticio podemos
entrar a un acuerdo de permutas de
incumplimiento crediticio contigo y así
en caso de haber fallos en los pagos lo
aseguraría y una vez hecho esto la
agencia de calificación bueno este de
aquí es un seguro éste es el tramo
prioritario de una garantía de
obligación de deudas el tramo
prioritario y ahora que este tramo está
asegurado por ahí que la agencia de
calificación crediticia le da una
calificación doble aa este tramo aunque
quizás está hecho de hipotecas de alto
riesgo aún siendo el tramo prioritario
así que tiene prioridad ante los otros a
fondo de pensiones compran todo este
tipo de cosas y último caso quizás
tienes un fondo de alto riesgo por aquí
un fondo de alto riesgo y que no le
quiere prestar dinero a nadie porque
está convencido de que quizás uno estas
compañías o quizás esta compañía por acá
esta compañía
calificada de otra manera esta es una
compañía con otra calificación este
fondo de alto riesgo está seguro de que
estas compañías le van a fallar en los
pagos y si llega a haber fallos entonces
este fondo de alto riesgo entra a un
acuerdo de permutas de incumplimiento
crediticio para así obtener aseguranza
pero sin tener que asegurar cosa alguna
es algo parecido a obtener seguro para
un auto pero el auto de alguien más el
carro de otra persona y tienes la
esperanza de que tenga un accidente algo
por el estilo porque si ahora este cuate
tiene una permuta de incumplimiento
crediticio en esta compañía de aquí sin
tomar en cuenta el hecho de que no le
prestaron el fondo de alto riesgo va a
dar un poco de dinero cada año y así
obtener el seguro teniendo la esperanza
de que esta compañía quiebre porque si
lo llegara a hacer entonces obtendrá el
pago del seguro van a obtener el mismo
pago del inversionista pero sin tener
que prestar el dinero entonces lo puedes
usar como una deuda adicional una manera
de hacer a los seguros de baja
calificación
aceptables a fondo de pensiones es una
manera directa de asegurar la deuda de
tus préstamos